hey it's technology tuesday and today
i'm talking about youtube videos and
whether i use a script or not
to make these videos happen so i got a
great question from one of my youtube
viewers love you guys james
wrote in to say i'm listening and
watching have to start my own videos i
love the messages or rants do you use a
script
or do retakes so james is a fantastic
question
and for any of you guys who are trying
to get started on youtube
i'm gonna explain my process before and
what i do now so when i first started
oh man it took me a long time to do a
video like an entire day to do one video
and i wasn't happy with it
and it would be all scripted it would be
totally scripted and i would try to
memorize it
word for word because i spent a lot of
time in writing great copy
and i wanted to be perfect and get my
points out exactly as i
as i wanted to the result was you could
see
in a lot of the videos that i'm
struggling to remember what i was saying
and i was so focused on saying the right
words
that i wasn't using feeling when i was
saying it
and so the content may be great but
there's no passion
and because there's not as much passion
in it people can't connect to it
and so i didn't have as many views and i
didn't have as many comments and didn't
as much engagement and i
i hated watching it too those were my
first videos and it took like an entire
day to do one video because you gotta
script it and memorize and practice and
do one sentence and come back and
practice in another sentence and so it
took a long time
now my process is i get a question
i'll think about it some of the
questions are
really easy so like this one i'm just
kind of
telling what i do so it's a little bit
easier some of them make me think and i
want to give concrete answers and i have
to think a little bit more about it
but usually what i'll do is i will read
the question on my computer
and then walk outside and and just walk
around in a circle a couple times and
and
do it so practice it go through a full
however long it takes five minutes
10 minutes whatever practice going
through it
and think about what points come up and
when i first do it it's not as eloquent
and like oh i get another idea and that
comes in and so
it comes out and it's not great as i go
through it and then i come in
and i mic up and i
answer just as just like what i did when
i was walking around but usually it's a
little more
eloquent and and thought out because i
had that one practice run
so that's the process now and so a video
might be
seven minutes long plus me walking
outside for 10 minutes
trying to figure out what i'm going to
say so it takes me that you know 17
20 minutes to do each video assuming i
have to do a little bit of thinking
for what the content is going to be but
you know i don't do
scripts now i don't do retakes uh
if i do a mistake i may say in the video
hey christina you know what let's let's
cancel that part out and
uh and i'll start over but it doesn't
really happen that much and if i do a
mistake i usually just keep it in and if
i miss a point whatever we keep going
on and some of the videos have me
doing some weird stuff at the end of it
you know if i forgot what i was gonna
say and i start dancing or whatever just
to try to refresh my memory
christina will pop those in at the end
of the videos it's kind of a bloopers i
wish i had more bloopers
and i think if i had people here it's
just me filming
then i probably have more bloopers and
jokes but i don't
anyway rambling what's important
is that you get started okay and i
wouldn't compare
you now to where i am now because
i had to go through i don't know how
many videos i have done now maybe 1200
a lot of them aren't published but i've
done like 1200 videos and so i've
learned a lot and i've had
years of practice doing this and i've
gotten better as i've gone along
and so it's not fair to compare where
you are now or you're just getting
started to what i'm doing now because
you may start
and you may try to go with no script and
you say oh this is too hard i can't do
it i'm never going to be successful i
suck i'm going to stop
whatever you need to get started that's
what you want to do
the most important thing is that you're
starting so if you need a script
use a script you need retakes do retakes
the most important thing is that content
is getting out there
because you need time to develop your
own style
it took me 800 videos
to get to the point where i could watch
my video and say
you know what that's not bad i kind of
like it obviously you're your own worst
critic and you're going to look at your
fish
first video and say wow that's so bad
nobody's ever going to care nobody's
ever going to watch it
put it up and then put the next one up
and put the next one up and again again
took me 800 videos before i got to the
point where i could
watch it and think it was half decent
so whatever helps you launch that first
video
do it what you'll find is you'll develop
your style
you look at how my videos have grown and
they're not the same
you know my videos now are not the same
as they were before and you look at any
popular youtube channel
people who've blown up and become
youtube celebrities you look at their
videos now
they're not the same as when they
started the ones when they started you
look i was like wow
it was so there's no effects you know
it's just that person in the field
whatever it is their style they're still
developing so it's still super rough
but that's part of your story and you
need to go through that journey
to get comfortable to get to the point
where you're in the flow and
your style will develop and that's okay
so you need to put in the hours you got
to put up the videos
whatever helps you get started do it and
when you send
your first one out shoot me a link
because i want to check it out
and see the first video that you put up
after watching this thank you and
believe
everybody watching you liked the video
support me by clicking on the link in
the description
leave a comment let me know what you
think let me know what your challenges
are
and click on my face subscribe to the
channel i will see you soon